okay the head of instagram adam mossari
is facing backlash four comments he made
on the recode media podcast an excellent
podcast with your kafka i've been on it
once or twice he basically compares
social media and the dangers of it to
the car industry let's listen to a
second clip and i'll give you my
feedback after
as head of instagram
do you feel
like the product should not be available
to certain kinds of people i mean if
this is something that gen that
genuinely could make and you don't know
yet right that you're saying we don't we
don't we're not fully confident in the
research but if there's a chance that
this is a product that could really harm
people in the same way that you know
cigarettes could harm people that you
guys should be restricting it or maybe
taking it off the market absolutely not
i and i really don't agree with the
comparison to drugs or cigarettes which
have very limited any upsides i think
that anything that is going to be used
at scale is going to have positive and
negative outcomes cars
have positive and negative outcomes
we understand that we know that more
people die than would otherwise because
of car accidents but by and large they
cars create way more value in the world
than they destroy and i think social
media is similar i think that we do a
ton to help people connect with those
that they love we've helped advance a
number of important social causes
particularly metoo and black lives
matter we help small businesses make a
living we help
creators find ways to express themselves
there's a bunch of them we give voice to
those who've been historically
marginalized there's a ton of value that
we create and but yes of course there
are also issues as well
all right they have it folks so
you know that quote in case you missed
it we know that more people die than
would otherwise because of car accidents
but by and large cars create way more
value in the world and they destroy and
i think social media is similar i mean
it's
fine i think using analogies is how we
figure out how new things impact us
couple things to think about with cars
um cars go through a lot of regulatory
uh testing and have massive amounts of
regulation in the beginning they had
none because they were new and then they
went through massive massive regulation
and
there was many actions taken against the
car industry because they knew that
airbags and seat belts and three-point
harnesses would have absolutely saved
more lives and they kind of took their
time in adding those because they added
a lot of cost to the car and a lot being
you know hundreds of dollars and it
would have saved millions of lives or
probably hundreds of thousands of lives
over the years since 30 000 people a
year i believe is the number die in car
accidents and there is a minimum age for
driving and people take
um
driving lessons and they get a driver's
license so
if mossari is a fan of this great uh
great metaphor how about kids have to
take a course pass a test uh and they
get a social media license if they want
to use social media before the age of 18
or 17 or whatever it is if we know
that um you know and it's proven that
this causes uh you know anxiety
depression etc in one third of uh teen
girls well then maybe they should take a
course before they get on it that seems
completely reasonable to me it seems
like the social media the downside to
social media might be actually more than
the downside to driving so great analogy
i'm sorry yeah let's regulate uh social
media for kids exactly the same way cars
are which is don't let them use it right
kids are not allowed to use social media
until they hit the age of 16 and there
are situations they're allowed to use it
in they're sometimes not allowed to go
on the highway right you get a learner's
permit you're allowed to use it but
during the daylight you have to have a
driver with you i like that analogy as
well what if to use social media your
parent had to be you know or your
guardian had to be on the side right
next to you in other words they had
access to the account they saw what you
posted maybe they approve what you post
they could easily build that into
instagram how about a tool where with
instagram you add who your parent or
guardian is i'm sorry and that person
then sees all of your interactions
everything you posted and everybody you
followed and they would give you the
ability to approve like i do on my
iphone
i will approve the apps my daughters
want to add they request it the parental
controls i edit so let's put parental
controls on instagram where if somebody
wants to post and they're an underage
person they're you know i guess 13 is
the starting age but
let's say anybody who's you know a
teenager not 18 yet their parents have
to approve their post before they post
it
easy to do right uh so i think uh
metaphors are helpful and i actually
kind of like this one um why not highly
regulate uh social media for kids it
makes total sense u.s news published an
article in february about the impact of
social media on teen girls mental health
here's a quote from that article we
found that girls who started using
social media at two to three hours a day
or more at age 13 and then increase that
use over time had the highest levels of
suicide risk in emerging adulthoods said
the study author sarah coyne she is an
associate director of the school of
family life at bringham young university
in provo utah
suicide rates of a hundred thousand
people in america have risen steadily uh
since social media took off in the late
2000s uh so if you look we would have 11
um if you look at this chart suicide
rates you know uh 10.8 11 10.9 up until
2006. and from 2006
uh we had straight up growth in the
number of suicides in the united states
that correlates exactly when facebook
twitter
snapchat instagram all became super
popular is that the correlation is it
opioids is it something else who knows
but it's definitely something that
is so obvious to anybody who's a parent
or anybody who's used social media that
social media is not something children
should use it's obvious to every parent
parents give into it i understand it's
really hard if the other kids in the
class have phones they have tic tac it's
hard to police you don't have unlimited
time we've all got to work and have
other obligations as parents but this is
where mussari needs to take more
ownership
and i would the idea is here they were
covering up this information about uh
you know these results at the same time
that they were proposing
instagram for kids so this is absolutely
crazy um i don't know if i like the
cigarette analogy um as much as i like
the car analogy
so uh another quick update uh on this
facebook fallout after the wall street
journal article published on tuesday
following happened three democrats from
both houses of congress sent a letter to
facebook ceo mark zuckerberg asking for
answers like
quote please provide copies of all
external research facebook has
commissioned or otherwise accessed
regarding the mental health
of your children and teen users
here's another quote please provide
copies of all internal research facebook
has conducted regarding the mental
health of your children and teen users
and third and finally a quote will
facebook agree to abandon his plans to
launch any new platforms for children or
teens including versions of instagram
for children if not
why not
so you're gonna see a lot more uh legal
investigations
and i think
facebook uh you know we should our
expectation is facebook cares more about
growth and revenue than they do our
children you should not trust facebook
with your information and you should not
trust them with your children
and certainly you should not trust the
chinese communist party
uh and let your kids use tik tok my best
advice to you as a parent and i'm not
saying this in a preachy way is no
social media until 16 or 17 that's going
to be our plan in our household
and i understand not everybody has the
resources i have or maybe there's us
you're a single parent and you don't
have the time to monitor everything
there are apps now that'll let you
monitor like our pack i think is one
where you can put this on your kids
phone or ipad and you can watch their
usage see what urls they open uh see
what instant messages and what they do
how much time they spend in each app and
in fact to block them from certain apps
and of course
none of this is perfect and i respect
your right to choose as a parent what
you think is the best but
uh lord um do some research on this
because and if you know anybody who lets
unbridled access to their kids i think
parents need to sort of team up on this
because if you have three or four kids
in a group who are allowed to use tick
tock and
four or five who are not we all know
what's going to happen they're all going
to share the tick tock and
you know probably something they
could handle at 16 17 18 years old
something like that but i think we all
know at 10 11 12 13 it's probably not
something they should be doing so it
takes a village
zendesk is the go-to tool for customer
support we all know that they also offer
a suite of tools designed to remove the
difficulties of cell's software so get
zendesk suite of sales tools plus their
industry leading support software for
free for six months as part of zendesk
for startups i'll show you how to do
that in just a moment but i want you to
know that you'll also get access to
zendesk's community of startup founders
and partners and will even offer
dedicated onboarding guidance and
support you know steezy studios it's one
of our portfolio companies and they sell
software to learn how to dance hundreds
of thousands of people are using that
software and they want to make sure
everybody has a great experience with
the software obviously so through a
combination of zendesk explorer and
their ticket tagging system steezy is
able to track which features their users
are most excited about and then relay
that to the product team so they're
using customer support
to make the product better so for steezy
zendesk creates a positive relationship
with their members and empowers them to
contribute this these growth in return
for some awesome dance moves get six
months of zendesk for startups free at
zendesk.com
qualify you must have under 50 employees
that's reasonable and you must have
raised a series a or below and be a new
zendesk customer couple conditions there
because they're giving you something
really valuable for free six months of
zendesk for startups start building the
best customer experiences at zendesk.com
twist